so what we
started with this year
is offering six basic training modules
and these six basic training modules are
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and data science so these are offered as
year-long
curricula that you can organize into an
asynchronous or a live
type course
our team supports it and actually runs a
number of these programs throughout the
year and dr mizunder will be speaking
about some of these programs when i'm
done with my part of the presentation
[Music]
in addition to that we also provide
specialization tracks and these include
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and
agriculture
includes also some elements of
biotechnology
so what we
are trying to do is develop exemplar
projects with curated data sets and an
explanation of methods that are sourced
from uh impactful publications in that
domain
to illustrate how some of those basic
data types as well as methods could be
applied to solve real research
challenges
now let me briefly explain what is the
difference between what i am describing
as a curriculum or as a content database
and some of the practical resources that
are included in this program and in this
training
so the omics logic program resources are
really designed around
training materials
computational tools that are easy to use
that biologists can use
interactive coding exercises that could
be first of all checked for syntax and
second of all checked for the correct
results and then finally an introduction
to a coding environment where you can
take some of the scripts that you've
learned how to write and then execute
them on a big data infrastructure so let
me briefly introduce some of these
resources in greater detail
one resource that is very critical for a
biologist to get started
is no code bioinformatics
and that means that you can use
bioinformatics without writing a single
line of code
and for that purpose we have a big data
analysis platform
that is
not unlike galaxy and some of the other
tools that exist out there but it is
tightly integrated with the curriculum
that we have designed for different
types of data and i'll briefly show this
platform today so that you can all get a
sense of what it really looks like and
how it works
the second part of this tutorial
approach is incorporating data science
and that means coding exercises that
check your ability to write correct
syntax without errors
and provide you with specific results to
the coding challenges so that you can
understand how to get the desired
outcome in your code
following a tutorial
and then finally we also are building a
network of mentors that can help you
take those skills further and so
essentially by working on exemplar
projects and trying to identify research
questions that could be answered with
data analysis skills we can then
eventually match you to a research
experience in which you can try to
understand a topic with the help of a
mentor that will eliminate some of the
dead ends and guide you to identify a
low-hanging fruit in terms of being able
to answer a research question as an
experience for you to gain computational
biology research skills
let me briefly
show you the resource that i mentioned
before so right here if you go under
courses
on the portal and by now i hope that
most of you have already created an
account i saw that some people joined
maybe a little bit late so i'll just
remind everyone this is a portal that we
are speaking about called omixlogic so
you can log in by following the link
learn.omixlogic.com
login is free you can gain access to
most of the resources for free and if
you are a part of one of our programs
through the nepe the national
association of idea principal
investigators you can gain access to all
of the resources that are mentioning
today for free using the nepi contract
that our company has
so here you will find different types of
courses materials and projects
right here you will find different tags
that you can try
and below are
collections that you can find focused on
different types of data different types
of skills
and one of those skills is the tbion for
platform that really establishes the
logic of analysis
applicable to big data
so what is this platform
this platform and by the way anyone that
wants demo account on this platform
after you have registered on the learn
portal and you have received your
password in your email
after 24 hours you will gain automatic
access to this platform
just to explore and see what it can do
so this platform is organized according
to several different sections you can
see here transcriptomics genomics
epigenomics
and different methods of analysis listed
on
this side there's also sections related
to mass spectroscopy and structural
biology
there are specific sections an
application to cancer biology single
cell analysis virology as well as data
integration and modeling so as you
look through these different sections
you'll find that some of them have a
drop down button
and this drop down button gives you
access to a demo pipeline builder that
you can try without having to upload any
data and without having to perform the
actual analysis so here for example you
will find that informative pop-ups that
are associated with each step of the
analysis will guide you
to build meaningful combinations of
scripts and algorithms that will produce
results that you can use so for example
in this transcriptomic section you can
see that i can perform mapping using bow
tie and then visualize the sam file
of the mapping that i performed and in
addition to this visualization i can
also find resources on the learn portal
that will allow me to
uh to understand what exactly i'm trying
to do
so this is just an example again you can
see that in many sections there's a drop
down that you can find different types
of uh different types of
you know methods of analysis and
different types of pipelines
that you can perform
so you can try and use that demo account
once you have created a login
so again that could be found
using coursework on tbioinfo and you can
see here a collection of courses that
you can explore and really learn how to
perform analysis of metagenomic genomic
transcriptomic and other types of data
now to illustrate how these kinds of
methods are used in a uh in a training
experience i want to briefly talk about
several different types of programs that
we run throughout the year
and then i will pass it on to dr
mizunder to speak about specific
programs that we have running right now
starting in the end of
january
so a good example of a program that we
regularly run is a program on
transcriptomic data analysis and so we
call this bulk and single cell
transcriptomics
the program is designed to introduce the
omix technologies including how the
library preparation happens how the
actual sequencing happens how does the
understanding of the methods of data
preparation
impact our analysis approaches to that
data and
ultimately how to then use some of this
methodology to actually be able to
perform large-scale
analysis using uh these kinds of methods
so
again starting from the t-bone for
platform that you just saw
we will
go through some example pipelines that
students build
they build those pipelines to understand
the inputs and the outputs behind each
step as well as the logic of analysis
how can they apply the right combination
of scripts and methods to achieve the
desired results and all of it is very
intuitive right as you can see there's
no coding involved
in addition to that the platform is
color coded and this color coding
follows a logic that we explain in
detail throughout the training program
itself
to apply those methods we then introduce
several different projects for example
cancer macrophages modeling cancer
precision medicine pdx tumor in the
micro environment but also
elements of infectious diseases like
malaria infection or even applications
in biotechnology and agriculture like
potato drought resistance for modified
crops
so that gives you an understanding of
the specific skills or specific methods
that need to be used and the specific
applications where you can actually try
and run that kind of analysis and see
what are the results what type of
insights you can generate analyzing such
data in addition to that we then go on
to one of the you know
maybe most exciting areas of
transcriptomic data analysis which is
single cell rna-seq analysis and we also
have a very basic processing pipeline
as well as a downstream analysis
pipeline for sailrat and monocle that we
go from the logic and then apply
all of the logic in terms of code that
could be run on google cloud platform
using google co-lab
so what happens is that you understand
the logic the need and the reason for
specific methods and then you can apply
the specific portions of that code to
try and modify and get the types of
figures that you might need for a
publication
moreover you will then see how the exact
same approaches are used in high impact
publications that are
really transforming our understanding of
different domains from cancer to
neuroscience using such techniques
so again
the objective in such a program in such
a basic program is to introduce the
specific type of data the methods that
are typically used to analyze such data
and then showcase some of the
applications of that data analysis
including multi-omics integration
another type of a program that i want to
briefly speak about is bioinformatics
for infectious diseases so one of the
things that really happened over the
past couple of years is that even people
who had no understanding of you know
mutations variants uh evolution and and
things like that really now know this
terminology and are even interested to
try and uh you know ask questions about
the huge amounts of publicly available
data related to the pandemic but also as
an extension of that related to many
other types of
epidemics or outbreaks that could be
occurring and so what we did is a couple
of years ago we worked with the
virologists here at the louisiana state
university uh understood how their
expertise in virology and bioinformatics
could be used for
creating these training modules and then
continued our collaborations with
researchers at ucsf stanford louisiana
state university georgetown medical
center as well as other regional centers
for example a large research consortium
on malaria to create project examples
that illustrate how similar types of
analytical methods could be applied to
analyze data and understand these
outbreaks of infectious diseases
so in this program we use project
examples related to the enterovirus
evd68 which was an outbreak that affects
primarily younger children and happening
recently in europe as well as in the us
malaria infection
again endemic in africa but also in many
regions of uh south america i believe
and
in asia sarskov ii which we all are
continuing to observe as well as the
ebola virus epidemic that not only
started the first
public and connected collection of next
generation sequencing data that is
publicly available but also produced
solid results including vaccines and
antiviral drugs that treated a disease
that was 90 percent
deadly before that
so as an extension of that we also offer
a focused analysis of source cove 2 as a
training module that many of the
research institutions that we work with
can use immediately because a big part
of the
sequencing and a big part of the
research questions around source code 2
are regional
and so by working with institutions like
louisiana state university where we did
many different projects on source codes
too including wastewater sequencing uh
we can train uh you know students and
researchers to be able to perform the
same and ask questions of the publicly
available data and so
on the learn portal that you have just
seen
you will see
this kind of an overview that gives the
basics of multiple sequence alignment as
well as the ability to ask questions
about origins of source code 2 or how
the new variants are emerging and how
they might affect the future of this
pandemic so at this point i briefly want
to introduce another element that i
think is critical for those students
that are serious about their interest in
bioinformatics
and what we see
time and time again is that
students going through short-term
training
are unable to capture a lot of the
aspects
of
bioinformatics the application of
bioinformatics but also the ability to
independently
learn and continue to apply
bioinformatics once those resources are
unavailable
and so for that reason we wanted to make
sure that many of the same methods
that are available through such training
could be taken away with the researcher
or the student after the program
completion and they're able to replicate
and even use those in their um
you know reporting or
ability to analyze data and so i briefly
want to show you a course that is
designed to kind of give you a broad
understanding of how this portal works
and that will be introduction to
bioinformatics so if you go to
introduction to bioinformatics
um
sorry
bytes and molecules is what i wanted to
say okay so bytes and molecules
the bites and molecules course
uh really covers many of the aspects of
what we just discussed for someone who
is a beginner and has minimum or no
background in bioinformatics wants to
understand the terminology that is used
in such training and wants to be
prepared with some of the technical
skills that are going to be needed
and one of the courses that will be
available in this
section is an introduction to coding
so coding
is an important part of a
bioinformatician's
you know day-to-day life and activity
but it is often seen as an exclusive
skill set that only bioinformaticians
and engineers really need to have but as
we all know in many aspects of research
just to produce the picture that you
need the figure
maybe some simple data analysis with
some statistical properties it is always
useful to be able to
know that piece of code that if you know
how to run it you know how to give it
the right input you can make it produce
the right output that you want and that
is exactly the objective of some of this
very basic introductory training that we
offer in this section called
introduction to bioinformatics languages
and this one is an example using r
so here you will find some very basic
things that you need to understand about
data how it is stored and how it is used
in the coding environment
but we don't have to set up a whole
environment on your own system to be
able to run and produce even the basic
plots that you might want to use in your
research publications or exploratory
analysis of a data set that could be
very informative
so we offer here
inside the actual lesson
a console that you can run
and get result
right here
and as you can see immediately if i just
run this piece of code i am getting an
error
and the reason is because obviously this
path to the file does not work right and
so one of the basic challenges that all
of us probably faced when we started
learning how to code i can learn how to
write hello world but how do i actually
make this code work for my data right
and that's exactly where we start so
just by copying this link
and replacing it right here in the
console
i can run the code
and i can get some results right and so
right here
you can see that
i can check the results
and now i have a successful result right
so i need to learn about some of the
syntax just some basics of writing how
to code i need to understand the logic
of how to find the right data and give
it the right link and then once i do
this console will check for me whether
i'm doing the right thing and now i can
extend this to more advanced
applications like running a script to
prepare a box plot or maybe
changing the way that this figure looks
right and eventually i will be
introduced to a an assignment and that
assignment will be right writing a
complete piece of code right so if i
know that i can complete this assignment
i'm not only following a step-by-step
tutorial but i'm in fact able to apply
what i have learned and now i can copy
this
and use it on my system to be able to
run that every time i face a result so
what kinds of activities are possible
for this type of
learning
one of the training that we do in terms
of source code 2 is performing multiple
sequence alignment and phylodynamics of
the pandemic outbreak in different
regions to really understand the
emerging variants or clades that have
been reported throughout the course of
the pandemic so as you can see the logic
of analysis is first done on the
platform
and then
we actually go through a series of steps
to generate a variant report and this is
a report not unlike what people use when
they use clinical reporting or or when
that reporting is being submitted to
you know maybe public health
institutions to understand whether there
is a particular variant of concern
or maybe there are some number of
samples that you know indicate that
there's a spread of that bearing of
concern so we go through preparing such
a report
in r how to install all of the different
tools that are needed on your own system
and then how to actually run that with
the specific types of variants that you
might be interested in so it really
provides an ability to apply the logic
try it on publicly available data and
potentially then
apply the same to novel data that is
being collected now we don't stay at the
sequence level we also try to
incorporate the association between
sequence and the structure so we look at
the spiked protein we understand the
spike protein and even map the mutations
and understand the relationship between
the proteins so that we understand how
they are interacting and as a result
understand the significance of some of
those variants and all of that is done
in under a month-long training program
now another big part of what we do
going beyond the traditional
bioinformatics where we deal a lot with
sequence data and visualization is
actually learn about data science and
for data science we have this very basic
introduction that i just showed you in r
and python but we also want to be able
to apply some of those methods of
exploratory data analysis statistical
analysis machine learning in a more
advanced environment and so we created
this program to offer
you know greater insights into what is
possible
just knowing some of those basics
again this is project oriented so we
start with
seemingly simple challenges for example
in the context of precision medicine can
we identify a patient that is likely to
respond or not respond to a particular
type of
medication
and then we use that information to be
able to explain some of the additional
downstream requirements for dealing with
bigger data how you can use different
packages how you can produce advanced
visualizations how you can apply similar
approaches to different types of data be
it genomic metagenomic transcriptomic
and others and eventually how to also
apply this using machine learning
you know advanced statistical analysis
and an understanding of how to apply
these skills to bigger data sets
now we've recently completed a program
like this that was you you know all of
it was designed around python
from very basics
to more and more advanced types of
applications where we also highlighted
the significance of an online
cloud-based environment to be able to
write reproducible code and i think
those are two very important trends that
students need to be introduced to as
they move into the application of
bioinformatics or data science to
particular types of research not only do
we need to be able to extract meaningful
insights we also need to know how we got
those insights and provide an
environment where others can easily
reproduce the same code that we write
which means that the code needs to be
readable which means that we need to
explain what we're doing and why we're
doing that and also highlight the
results
with a piece of code that somebody can
take and
run and and get the exact same thing and
so there we cover things like uh you
know
dimensionality reduction uh ordination
and embedding
we look at different types of
classification models including the
understanding of how those models work
and how principles of those
logistic regression for example methods
are used in
more advanced methods like deep learning
and also
connect that with again practical
examples and those practical examples
could be used for uh
projects that have made a significant
impact so after we cover this domain of
machine learning we actually take a look
at several different publications where
all of the methods that we cover are
explained in the abstract itself and the
student can really see and appreciate
how the
specific outcome from some research
really affected
the industry or even the clinical use of
those methods so for example here
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer is a project that we use to
illustrate individualized and
personalized treatment as well as
predictive modeling to understand
potential response that does not require
data from that patient themselves over a
course of different types of treatments
right which is obviously not possible
and i think very relevant to the medical
field which is moving further and
further into the adoption of such tools
and the precision treatment of
different types of complex diseases
now
beyond this training and i'll i'll be
done here in a couple of minutes we
offer
to use the same elements that i've just
described the t by info platform for no
code bioinformatics the coding elements
that you can embed right into your
coursework your expertise in projects by
illustrating a specific type of a method
in application to a data set that you
understand and might have published
before
as a resource for researchers and
faculty that would like to incorporate
their own training and make it available
to the nepu network so one of the ideas
is to
identify gaps
for example if you take an institution
that might not have a full
bioinformatics
core
and they might not have the
you know facilities to be able to
support bioinformatics and computational
biology research
we would like to match them with another
institution that might have those
capabilities but might be lacking
another capability that that university
does have and so by linking those we're
able to address the gap across the whole
network
one example that i would like to show is
a course that we designed together with
dr sona vasudevan
she is the program director at the
georgetown university medical center for
a program called systems medicine and
her special is her specialty is in
bioinformatics using 3d protein
structures and really uh kind of looking
at the relationship between sequence and
structure and so we worked with her to
create a summer course where her
students and students from other uh
backgrounds could join and and learn the
basics of genomics in the virtual lab
we also worked with researchers that
specialize in oncology
developing a program on precision
oncology and
we also kind of design these together in
collaboration with other researchers and
faculty and we are hoping to expand our
network and really uh kind of build the
same model of
the context the methodology and examples
of applications using curated data sets
to expand the library of resources that
we're offering now we've done these
programs over the year
the several years now
in several different institutions
we do have a lot of
kind of feedback from different users
including students faculty researchers
and we are starting to work with
industry as well not only to provide the
basic training
and the path to research but also for
students that are interested in a path
to an industry career right where
bioinformatics is a highly desired
profession and skill set and can really
make a difference in someone pursuing
that direction
so thank you again for listening to my
part of the presentation it took a
little bit longer than i anticipated but
i would like to pass this on to dr mohit
mizunder who will speak about some of
our ongoing programs that we have
started in january
and are now